You do know
you need not dress
so formally here?
Does this
meet your approval?
Oh, without question.
Your Grace, should we...
go upstairs?
I have a better idea.
Where are we going?
Out!
-So?
-Yes?
Now that we have returned
to the motherland,
we must revert
to our real identities.
So, if you see me
on the street...
Yes, of course.
I am a true professional.
It's been a pleasure
working with you, comrade.
Pleasure's mine.
Wait, wait, wait.
Really?
That's it?
You're just gonna walk away
like this never happened?
That's what
professionals do, right?
Sarah, I just had
the best day of my life.
John B,
you're gonna blow our cover.
Look, I don't care
about my cover, Sarah.
I don't care
if my friends find out
or your boyfriend
with his frosty tips.
Look, yesterday,
I, I didn't even know
who you were.
And today, I'm like...
Sarah Cameron.
And honestly,
in my limited experience,
that's rare.
That's like,
like eclipse rare,
like a blind person
seeing colour
for the first time rare
or like Bigfoot evidence
or the Northern lights.
Look, I can't pretend
like this isn't real.
Like this didn't happen.
-I'm sorry.
-Shut up.
I can't pretend either.
Hey, man. Get a room.
Hi. It's me again.
Is Maeve here?
Yeah. Yeah.
She's in the back garden.
Hey.
Hi. What are you doing here?
I...
I needed to talk to you.
What's, what's going on.
It was never
about the clinic.
I did the clinic
to be close to you.
And then you made me realise
I'm good at something.
And I like helping people.
And I thought
you ignored my message
and it crushed my heart.
And I stopped
doing the clinic
because it reminded me
of you and it sucked.
So, I wanna help people.
And I know this is only
about the money for you,
but... let's just be a team.
Again. Please?
Because if I can't
be with you romantically,
I still wanna see you
every day.
Nothing feels right
when you're not around.
It wasn't just
about the money for me.
I wanted to be close too.
Noah!
Why didn't you write me?
Why?
It wasn't over for me.
I waited for you
for seven years
and now it's too late.
I wrote you 365 letters.
I wrote you every day
for a year.
-You wrote me?
-Yes!
It wasn't over.
Still isn't over.
Sure I can't give you
a ride home?
I think if my mom saw me
getting off your motorcycle,
she'd come out
with a shotgun.
That's fair enough.
Jug?
What you said at Pop's.
I heard you.
Whatever you need to do
or explore.
I support you.
You have a knack
for getting in trouble.
for saving my life.
I think
I have a superhero stalker.
I was in the neighbourhood.
You are amazing.
Some people don't think so.
But you are.
Nice to have a fan.
Do I get
to say thank you this time?
Wait.
I'm sorry.
I'm so sorry for...
what you've been through.
Nobody forced me to...
get behind the wheel
that night.
That's a...
that's a choice I live with.
Yeah, but everything else.
Ryan manipulating
the justice system.
Somebody should stop him.
I volunteer happily.
Well, I am working on it.
I just met a new lawyer
for dinner last night.
Lawyer,
you weren't on a date.
He thinks
joint custody is doable
if I can just show
how I'm really doing now.
And judge sees it.
If was sure
Ryan could never find us,
I would grab Juliet
and run to Paris.
And spend our days
drawing outside Sacré-Cœur.
That sounds magical.
For you.
Tragic for me to lose you.
I shouldn't have reduced you
to my issues.
You're nothing
like my mother.
You adore your child
and she should be with you.
You're just who you are.
You don't hide or embellish,
you own your mistakes
and stand up
to the strikes against you.
You're so...
Oh no! Please no.
It's okay. Look.
I think it's just us.
Oh shit.
Love is gonna kill you.